i feel like um
it really is a battle between good and
evil
and i think many of these establishment
cultists think it's a battle of good and
evil too and i think they're wrong about
that because they're in a cult
they they they come on they say oh all
trump supporters are in cults these
people who are you know eating horse
pace they're all they're all insane and
the stories are often fake i mean
they're often fake with the story about
uh oklahoma being overrun with you know
gunshot victims couldn't get right
totally fake story totally fake story we
have this story from uh uh timecast.com
about jimmy kimmel
kimmel says unvaccinated americans
taking ivermectin should be left to die
if they get sick actually it's a little
we'll break that apart he actually said
that if someone comes in who's
unvaccinated eating horse goo rest in
peace wheezy
and then he said we still got a lot of
pam dimwits out here people are still
taking this ivermectin this the poison
control centers have seen the spike in
calls from people taking livestock
medicine to fight the coronavirus but
they won't take the vaccine it's like
you're a vegan and you're like no i
don't want a hamburger give me that alpo
instead one of the reasons these sea
biscuits are opting for ivormectin is
because they don't trust big pharma
which is fine i guess except for the
fact that ivormactin is made by merck
which is the fourth largest
pharmaceutical company in the world and
even merck is telling people to cut it
out
so i'm not here to get into the medical
debate with jimmy kimmel i'm going to
talk about the the overt callousness
there was another story i saw from this
mainstream journalist who said we need
to stop shaming people who are doing
things we don't like and the reason was
she said
when these stories like with jimmy
kimmel come out when the oklahoma story
comes out her dad turns it off and stops
listening saying this is negative it's
lies manipulation i don't want to hear
it anymore
so they outright don't trust the media
they don't trust big pharma i think it's
a fair point to say
we shouldn't like the fact that he's
like rest in peace wheezy that's insane
that's like a dark thing to say about
someone how about what if he said this
recipes fatty oh what's that you had a
heart attack and you're overweight too
bad no we don't do that we say we're
gonna try and save you when we don't do
this we
we don't do this with the flu
you know yeah people have a choice of
flu shots i understand they're different
it is it's different but we you don't
shame people for getting
sick
and it's almost like it's it's the
reason why it's so dark is this he's
he's cal he said he's callous about he's
almost wishing for it to happen
and that's just so wrong these i'm i'm
i'm really angry man i just gotta say i
the media is the most destructive vile
and disgusting entity in this country
and i mean the corporate press
because when they come out with this
stupid
bs about oklahoma call centers and and
cnn says livestock you get people so
distrustful of our institutions they
literally go to tractor supply instead
that's your fault jimmy kimmel that's
your fault aaron burnett if you people
weren't so despicable maybe people might
actually say you know what the vaccine
my doctor says is a good idea instead
now they're like people messaging me
saying don't even trust their own
doctors anymore and i'm like well look i
understand being mad at the mainstream
media and people like jimmy kimmel being
vile disgusting despicable people
but yo
to then turn around and say i'm going to
distrust all institutions this is the
problem i have i don't blame the regular
working class person i don't blame the
regular person who's confused by this i
blame these vile people like aaron
burnett who come out and say joe rogan's
eating livestock medication which is a
absolute lie i'm almost swearing on this
one because this is why i'm reading this
story i'm reading this quote from jimmy
kimmel and i'm like isn't it crazy that
there are people willing to go to
tractor supply instead of going to a
doctor that's your fault cnn that's your
fault aaron burnett that's your fault
jimmy kimmel is is jimmy kimmel is that
monologue uh is that on youtube right
now oh probably because this is the
point that i was making about so jimmy
kimmel
can go on to youtube and advocate for
violence and death against a certain
group of people and that's fine and this
is what breeds the distrust and the
contempt and the anger what about on
twitter you have people saying oh if
people aren't vaccinated and they get
the coronavirus they shouldn't be they
shouldn't be hospitalized so what
they're basically saying is that people
who
decide that they're going to
ignore
ignore what the professionals say and go
out and maybe contract the virus
shouldn't get medical advice
wow i wonder if somebody would have said
that in the 80s during the hiv
it's just a horrible thing to do or say
about during the aids thing it's just a
horrible thing to do to say about
anybody and you want to be for universal
healthcare and think healthcare is a
human right
tell jimmy kimmel to go shove it because
if you're one of these bernie sanders
supporting progressive socialists and
you think healthcare is a human right it
doesn't matter if you're overweight then
it doesn't matter if you're
i don't know you eat legos
are we gonna if some guy sticks a fork
in an outlet don't do that
are we gonna be like no it's his fault
he chose to do it we're gonna be like
this man needs help save him these
people are evil they're evil they're the
ones who go on tv and mock
here's my favorite example
donald trump ordering a well done steak
with ketchup brilliant move trump's a
smart guy legend remember this straight
legend yes yes do you remember this
when donald trump ordered a well-done
steak with ketchup yeah yeah yeah you
know why that was a master a master a
master stroke a genius maneuver
it's 4d chess baby because the media
came out and made fun of him for doing
it they made fun of him for having this
fancy steak well done with ketchup ha ha
what a [ __ ] and then regular people who
aren't wealthy you can't afford filet
mignon said i get my my steaks from the
local supermarket from the save on or
whatever and i put ketchup on it
trump was more relatable one of the
greatest gifts that he gave this country
and i think so many of his policies were
just so good for for the country but but
uh
the fact that he did expose
the media
for who they really were i mean there
was always sort of like a a veneer like
of
maybe maybe not well there's a liberal
by but trump
exposed them for just exactly who they
are and they've never quite recovered
or they've never recovered at all the
media has almost no credibility anymore
you you were mentioning politicians
getting bullied by the press i mentioned
fauci fauci is talking on some show i
can't remember samantha guthrie or
something and he was asked about well if
one mask works why not two masks and he
says yeah it's just common sense to wear
two masks
and then and then he comes out later on
tv and says no there's no guidance
saying to wear two masks
then the cdc later comes out and says
we're two masks because it is true also
that there are people in government who
are pressured by the media
i don't think there's a grand conspiracy
i certainly think there's interests in
government and corporations that have
influence and affect things what i think
is happening is
we are a country of
i'll be careful we have a lot we are a
country of a large number of cowards
absolute cowards and so that means when
the crackpots say stupid things regular
people say leave me alone i don't want
to get involved we talked about
institutions and not being trusted in
this so did you see the story that broke
today the cdc titan masking guidelines
after threats from teachers union yeah
this this is why everything is political
the radical left has penetrated
institutions to the point where
average people don't trust don't trust
our institutions anymore the system is
for good reason right and so i i think
trump exposed a lot of that and i think
ultimately that
it makes our country in in the long haul
i think it makes our country a better
a better place because the hope is
is that people will start thinking
critically again but we need to start
mitigating the fact that the left
is in charge i mean and i really
honestly believe the only way that you
can do that is to
without bringing secession into it how
about local politics i mean really make
local politics more important like so
gun laws i don't think there should be
any gun laws i think the second
amendment is you know and i agreed i
yeah i
i catch crap for this because i don't
know about constitutional gun laws
according to somebody and um but
so
what did texas just do texas just said
that if a suppressor is made in texas
you can go in and you can buy it without
your 200 nfa tax stamp
well
the reason they can do that is because
they tell the texas rangers they tell
local police that
if the atf comes in don't
don't coordinate with them right don't
give them any cooperation that's what
small towns should be doing and so a
town should be like i mean the atf then
doesn't know who has it and then and
then there's the fact that
my friend michael bolden from the 10th
amendment center looked and said like in
2014
the atf
the dea did not have the budget to bust
every dispensary in los angeles county
once wow
so they don't have the kind of budget
that we think that they have
so i think local politics is just really
the way forward and i think that's
what's going to br that's what's going
to mitigate all this left
craziness i mean it's you just if you're
in a right town if you're in a town that
leans right talk about talk to your
neighbor about it i'm moving to a
smaller town i got to talk to neighbors
like the second day i was there and that
was better than anything i had done in
atlanta in 15 years
and
you should be organizing and you should
be talking to people about how
talking to the police i mean the problem
with the police
i mean i think there's a big problem
with the police in this country they
just have too much to do
there's just too many things for them to
do i mean they should be investigating
crimes i think the numbers are that they
show up to stop a crime uh less than
five percent of the time so they're
basically investigators so
make them investigators make them the
best investigators possible i i think
you're so right about the
the the local politics and it's
something that the left has understood
for a long time now
and they will actually recruit county
commissioner candidates and move them to
states where they think that they can
win
and you have people
like very very wealthy leftists and they
they they rolled out their digital
fundraising platform and act blue
but far before conservatives had our own
response and win red they're essentially
the exact same platform except for
there's an algorithm base it's sort of
like the netflix of giving if you like
this guy you might like this guy and as
you get more donors you have a bigger
rolodex you can raise more money and
raise it faster but the left has a big
head start on republicans in that
in that regard um but
the the left is under is understood for
a very long time
that you've got to organize
all the time you can't stop you can't
just organize for an election and then
everybody goes home and this is
something that i i've been working
really hard at in pennsylvania is is
telling people that hey
we have to organize all this because the
number one thing that i get on campaign
is what what can i do you know i'm just
one person i'm like well that's enough
like get out there bring people together
and organize and advocate for the things
that you believe in get behind can't it
might not even be me but get behind
candidates that you believe in help them
make phone calls help them knock doors
talk to your neighbors talk to the
police
get involved at the local level organize
24 7 because that's what the left does
and that that's that's that's the
pathway to victory that's how we save
this country there's a dude in new york
you put up a video where he's going
around with these flyers say we do not
discriminate on race creed uh you know
vaccine are unvaccinated we welcome all
and he says a bunch of stores agreed to
put the signs up and so he just went out
and now all these businesses are saying
like we're not gonna adhere to this
mandate one person one guy and so i'm
like amazing people in new york should
be doing this yeah yeah that was so
great yeah people in new york you should
hear this that's cool yep yep so i
tweeted him out not you know included
his handle i don't have it pulled up
otherwise you know but uh you can go to
my twitter at tim cast and then you can
see the video he made and he's just some
dude he's a big account he's not some
prominent actress he like made the video
he put it up on tick tock and twitter
someone tweeted it i saw it i retweeted
it i told people in new york get active
if you have a problem with what's going
on you can't just sit back and ignore it
that's exactly right that's exactly
right and that's what we've been working
on in pennsylvania and i think it's
working i think i really do think that
2022
i mean first of all we've got to win in
2021 i mean you talked about like that
there's not going to be like if you know
the left doesn't fear the an antifa type
response from the right and i think
by and large i think that's a good thing
like the right is like we're law and
order we believe in that and and i think
that's a good thing
um but you see it like we have our
judicial races in in pennsylvania we
elect judges in pennsylvania for some
reason not i'm not sure quite how i feel
about that i don't like that
um because there's really no state
contribution limit right so you have
like one super rich billionaire be like
well here's a million bucks go win your
judge race and all of a sudden as if
you're a leftist you you
like almost all leftist judges
uh legislate from the bench they don't
follow the constitution they just
legislate from the bench and so well
anyway we have we have we have we got to
win these we got to win in 2021 but i
think we're going to
i think we're going to because we you
know in 2021 we won the ballot
referendums in pennsylvania that that
curb governor wolf's unilateral
authority to declare emergencies because
he just like kept extending covet
emergencies like in perpetuity well we
won that and rep as republicans by 139
000 votes so i think that
people were waking up to this i really
do and you i i'm saying all this to say
it's not just a feeling i see it
empirically as well and i think going
into 2022 with biden is just he just
destroys everything that he touches i
think people
people see it and california will be
interesting whether newsome gets
recalled because you know 538 saying
that he's favored now a bunch of polls
come out saying oh it's over for the
recall effort you know he won
we'll see there was uh there's one dude
colin moriarty posted a photo he got in
virginia of a california recall ballot
huh in virginia what how do you
accidentally mail outside of your state
for your own state's gubernatorial
election
whatever
but um
i think we'll we'll see because i think
a lot of democrats don't like them
there's a lot of democrats in california
probably like another business they're
owners they're business owners and they
they watch their business collapse
because of ridiculous government madness
i mean i think that
what california have they even lifted
their lock down yet did they ever
officially lift their lockdown remember
that video of that woman who had a
restaurant and she said
outside right not allowed to have an
outdoor seating area but right next to
it is the craft service yes for a movie
production and they're allowed to do
this yes it's insane the rich get richer
the government in the last year
made people close their businesses stay
home and they actually made their loved
ones die alone and people listened
this is a huge problem this is this is a
this is a real bringing that up people
don't care leftists don't care let's
face it i mean the left is the one who
has bought into this coveted religion
and they don't care if you bring that up
then you're just well it's like they
were going to die anyway i mean
and we have another problem in this
country with warehousing our warehousing
are old
you know warehousing our grandparents
instead of having three generation
households like my family does in puerto
rico
it has a lot
it's actually a really interesting point
i i do think that
that the breakdown of the family unit in
in this country and even neighborhoods
like when i grew up uh in in i we had a
neighborhood we would talk to our
neighbors we'd go out and play in the
cul-de-sac
with friends and
i just feel like
that doesn't exist anymore people who
are more insular
then the restrictions in the lockdowns
are a good thing aren't they
what are we seeing more of the great
resignation the job openings are not due
to people
necessarily getting free money a lot of
people have decided with unemployment
they're like why why would i look for
work so i think we'll see some we're
going to see a lot of jobs get filled
now that the unemployment benefits are
are over
but a lot of people are have been
resigning
10 mil i think 11 million in three
months from april to july
or from april june and why is that
because
they don't want to do these jobs anymore
they've been given a taste of remote
work what does that mean when you work
remote
you see your kids
you wake up you see your kids see them
off to school you pick them up you bring
them home you hang out with them i think
a lot of people realize they like doing
that
so now you're hearing a lot of stories
about people saying i don't want to go
back to the office if they don't let me
work remote i'll quit
and so businesses that can have remote
are now are now are doing this take a
look what's happening in schools
parents are getting fed up with schools
well if you work remote you don't need a
babysitter and you don't need your kid
to be in the school you can do a pod
where your you know 10 families put all
their kids together and then hire a
teacher together it's super cheap for
family and then you have one teacher
teaching all these different subjects
that's i think is going to restore a lot
of family and community and whether it's
on purpose or not
i think you're you're you're going to
start seeing a return to a lot of family
values parents teaching their kids
i think i think there's a there's a
light at the end of the tunnel here i i
agree i agree if if her
gosh there i don't i hate to even speak
about it this way because
but but
people were paying more attention
because of of the pandemic
and the lockdowns they're paying more
attention to what their kids are
learning in school and i think that's
why you see just such intense passion
around these school board races because
parents are finally like wait a second
what the heck is this stuff and so
they're involved now they're fired up i
mean every every week we see some like
some viral video of a parent at a school
board meeting telling the board members
what for and getting their mics cut and
stuff so that is certainly a good thing
and and i do think that that teachers
unions now
you know i was when 9 11 happened and i
joined the military i was an elementary
education major i was trying to figure
out how i was going to student teach
second grade it's something that like i
i think i have tons of respect for
teachers like you know but
but the teachers unions i think most
people see them today for what they are
and they're putting their bureaucratic
needs over their union before the
educational needs of the student
and i think more people today that the
whole pod concept that you talked about
is is kind of interesting it's
fascinating but school choice is
something that matters to people thanks
for checking out this clip from the tim
cast irl podcast if you want to see the
full show come back to this channel
youtube.com tim cast irl monday through
friday at 8pm where you can leave
comments and super chat and we actually
will read your comments on the show
don't forget to like share subscribe and
if you want exclusive members only
content segments you can't get anywhere
else go to timcast.com become a member
and we even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you